So here's something to think about.
This is a way of approaching what Rogers was up to.
Imagine how you use words.
No,
you could use words instrumentally.
Let's start with that.
If imagine that you want something from someone and then you might think,
well,
how can I phrase my argument so that I'm going to get that from this person?
And then you might say,
well,
what sort of argument would appeal to that person and what buttons can I push
and how can I get what I want?
And then you're using words in an instrumental way.
You're using them as tools to obtain what you desire from other people.
Now,
I think if you do that completely,
you're a psychopath.
I mean that because a psychopath has no room for you at all.
It's about him or her and you're there to be used as an instrumental target.
Now,
I'm not saying that every time someone uses language instrumentally,
they're acting like a psychopath,
but
that's the logical conclusion to that form of language use.
Now then you might think,
well,
you can ask little kids tried to do that to their parents,
right?
Siblings will often collude,
we'll have a little conspiratorial conversation about how to approach one parent
or the other.
Usually by isolating the parents,
that's a good strategy.
And then they'll phrase their requests so that they can extract out the desired
benefit.
Um,
I follow these pickup artists online,
um,
being very interested in their use of psychology.
And they are instrumental language users,
right?
So their trick is they're developing a whole little hope,
hurry of verbal tricks that they use in attempts to seduce.
It's a very narrow focus and it's instrumental language.
It,
it's as if that the personhood of the,
of the target is irrelevant fundamentally.
So it's a fairly pathological,
it can become pathological,
very easy.
So then you might say,
well,
how would you use language if you weren't using instrumentally?
Because you know,
you have to have a career and you have to be goal oriented.
You have to be aimed towards things.
And so since you have to be goal oriented,
how can it be other than that,
you would use language instrumental.